on commence avec donc ce top 10 des
dards cas avec un mec qui a dû regretter
ne pas mieux avoir dormi la veille
ça s'est passé cette semaine et l'image
est assez ou c'est un ouvrier qui s'est
endormi sur son transpalette regarder ça
c'est complètement où vous regardez ses
bas
[Musique]
une histoire de paracétamol benjamin
voilà qui devait être certainement avec
un regard de bar de voir que le
téléphone à bussac les normes ça je
croyais même pas rien et vous remettez
la scène questionné par ailleurs
regardez chez vous incroyable mais que
s'est endormi le pauvre gardien
[Musique]
le pauvre en deuxième position on a vu
le mec qu'a voulu tenter un challenge et
qui doit bien le regretter c'est simple
ils devaient faire peur à sa femme au
moment où affluent les vrais sa capuche
fille et ça se passe pas du tout comme
prévu regarder et la lcp qu'albert ils
s'étaient calmées quelle position des
visions d'arcade hulot a bien sûr vous
aurez votre top 20 tout à l'heure à
20h48 le confinement c'est compliqué
pour tout le monde mais j'ai
l'impression que pour certains c'est
carrément une catastrophe
regardez le rappeur jul y voilà il
regardait il a énormément changé pendant
le confinement regardez c'est notre
numéro 8
[Musique]
si je m'en vais a rappelé christophe
peut-être qu'on soit vers là-bas tu me
diras tant que personne n'est parfait
on s'est juste un loupé mais lui je le
kiffe et limogés belle jusqu'au 3 mai
pratique mois que je joue en effet déjà
au sein des politiques et rigolades du
jour on voulait prendre des nouvelles de
bouder vous devez vous le savez les
contenus avec son fils et depuis le
début il galère un peu à lui faire faire
l'école à la maison
cette fois c'était un cours de musique
c'est numéro 7 regardez notre pote au
bout des quais d'arc a inscrit les
quatre saisons passées très simple et
quatre saisons c'est un grand grand
pitié ces épisodes
c'est eux qui ont créé les cas de saison
ou si antonio vivaldi
as-tu parlons musique même si c'est dans
la musique
vivaldi elle a fait quatre saisons celui
qui est le créateur d'épisodes nom n'est
le mettrais nous indique c'est un
compositeur des chansons écoute le
maître qui peut pas tout vous dire il
est tenu par le secret médical
il est génial notre bouder que j'aime
forts vont bouder en sixième position en
ce moment on a tous du temps pour se
trouver de nouvelles passions et il ya
une meuf elle a trouvé la sienne faire
de la combe où chaque maison c'est une
boisson traditionnelle là comme bush
avoue avait déjà bu de l'eau comme bush
au nom gilles n'ont même pas mais alors
ensuite elle a voulu montrer ils
commencent à se buvait mais je sais pas
si c'est vraiment utile
regardez ces numéros 6
[Musique]
je prends pas ce vendredi à berlin
alors là qu'au bout de chasse et une
boisson a saisi des obtenu en cultivant
des bactéries et de la levure dans une
boisson sucrée
ces effets sont soi-disant bénéfique
pour la santé
voilà il dit mais bon papa papa pour la
pour la santé oui mais pour
l'appartement non trop de la rue entre
deux murs merci tous mes amis c'est
drôle en cinquième position on a trouvé
un mec qui comme beaucoup de monde en ce
moment c'est fabriqué un masque maison
le problème c'est qu'apparemment il
avait pas de qui suit alors je vous
laisse découvrir avec quoi il a fait son
masque regarde ouais non un gâteau il ya
des mariannes l'atoll essayons de mettre
ta pas au top 5 des rivales du jour
pendant le coach en numéro 4 on passe
donc à la quatrième place de ce top 10
avec un petit cours de danse c'est un
cours de pole dance précisément et les
chéris la pole dance on le dit jamais
assez c'est très sexy mais c'est
également extrêmement des gardes
[Musique]
oh là là ça fait mal ça fait mal alors
j'ai eu tout le monde au téléphone tout
le monde va bien sachez le c'est bon
tout le monde va bien tout le monde est
au top au numéro 3 il ya un jeu que je
kiffe c'est le tu préfères tu savais tu
préfère vivre avec jean michel maire
voilà pendant huit ans mais sans
l'embrasser ou du préfet redis avec
gilles verdez cependant omis jour en
l'embrassant tous les jours voilà c'est
une question que me suis souvent posé
rien je dis donc c'est ça et à chaque
fois il ya des dilemmes de ouf
vous savez moi j'ai jamais su croire en
bombardant de la sto réparer entre les
deux je sais pas trop la pallice et le
choléra mais j'aime les deux y'a un mec
qui n'a pas hésité longtemps
il a même attendu on regarde alors j'ai
un truc qui se met il a même attendu la
deuxième proposition en fait regarder il
n'a même pas attendu la deuxième
proposition parce que j'ai un truc qui
c'est qui est venu sur mon ordi l'ancien
des russes à dire oui et c'est pas le
corps d'un virus elle regarde et il a il
habite du temps il a pas mis du temps je
veux dire il a même pas attendu la
deuxième proposition pour choisir ce tu
préfère regarder ces numéros 3 ok dan
youtube et cinq crans à bbb
l'ag direct alors que la position on a
une grand mère qui faisait une petite
sieste au calme mais ça c'était avant
que son petit fils ait envie de la
réveiller il a une technique très
particulière
regardez c'est le numéro 2 des rigolades
du jour sur install twitter sur tout ce
qu'on a trouvé sur les réseaux regarde
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon là pour
moi m'a fait de la peine
moi je pourrais pas faire ça je vous
jure que c'est vrai ça me fait beaucoup
de peine pour sa part le fait de la
peine allez au numéro un on arrive au
top 1 de notre top 10 des rigolades du
jour et en ce moment la série qui
cartonne dans le monde c'est bien sûr la
quatrième saison de casa del pape est
alors il ya bien sûr validé chez nous et
casa del papel alors vous allez voir que
le professeur et compagnie ils doivent
faire face au confinement on est tombé
sur une parodie exceptionnel vous
connaissez tous casa del papel ou bien
regarder ça vous allez kiffer c'est très
fort c'est le numéro un du jour craquer
les tâches opel corona j'ai tenté de te
protéger
mais il a fallu que tu sortes est ce que
tu peux m'expliquer ce qui t'a pris
d'aller voler plus de 184 rouleau de pq
il faut que tu me promet d'arrêter de
faire des courses pour 30 personnes
je t'en supplie raquel regarde moi il
faut que tu me promettent
bon d'accord je vais te le dire poliment
et complètement conne
c'est vraiment très drôle voilà et c'est
très fort ce que je fais actuellement
voilà c'était notre j01 du jour vous